[Music]
hi everyone it's bobby lieber and
welcome to your favorite podcast where i
talk about whatever i feel like talking
about
so these big movie producers came to me
and said we want you to write a rom-com
about a gay couple
something a straight guy might even like
and watch with his girlfriend gay guys
are my jam awesome something a straight
guy might like am i gonna be in the
middle of some high-speed chase then all
of a sudden fall in love with ice cube
am i gonna get [ __ ] by jason mamoa
while we're both worrying about a
volcano
they said we just want a movie that
shows the world that gay relationships
and straight relationships are the same
love is love is love i said love is love
is love no it's not that is [ __ ]
our friendships are different i have to
go to a party and you're too old to be
in the pool
please leave our sex lives are different
aspect don't have ass pic must see pick
of ass
took this just for you bro
did he block me our relationships are
different this is bisexual awareness
week and no one has acknowledged it
lesbian history month was in march
nobody said a goddamn thing of course
lesbians get a month and we get a week i
don't want any hollywood [ __ ] no
scenes where two guys are about to hook
up and all of a sudden the camera
conveniently pulls away
oh
hey i'm gonna go this is nice meeting
you yeah youtube is lovely
[Music]
my whole life i prided myself on being
self-reliant
what is going on with you this
[ __ ] has gone into my head
[Music]
what are you into one of these [ __ ]
ripped idiots with no opinions no i'd
like someone who's physically very frail
and won't stop talking
maybe you're both bottoms and that's the
problem
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god gay sex was more fun when
straight people were uncomfortable with
it
anyway it doesn't matter i'm not the
right person to ride a rom-com anyway
[Music]
oh my god do you guys remember straight
people yeah they had a nice run
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you